I made it through the wilderness somehow
nope you're not crazy that is an
uncovering Madonna's like a virgin and
doing a beautiful job hi I'm Sylvia
Lacey and this is trending on 80 now
sister Christina Cuccia also known as
the singing nun won a recording contract
with Universal after stealing the show
on Italy's version of The Voice if you
missed the story the first time around
sister Christina made headlines with her
impressive pop covers take a look at her
audition
now sister Christina has released her
debut single a stripped down version of
Maja's controversial hit but hear her
out
don't stop
slang
like
it's too much
the 26-year old nun told the Catholic
newspaper of Annie ray that she sees the
song as more of a quote secular prayer
than a pop song if you read the lyrics
without being influenced by what has
gone before you discover that it is a
song about the capacity of love to make
people new again to release them from
their past she said as translated by the
Guardian so is that woman on is actually
singing about back in 1984 of course I'm
a fan of the original but I'm kind of
loving this new version too but I want
to know what you guys think tweet me at
Sophie Chalet see using the hashtag ET
now and stick with ET online forum or
trending fun